what if my word doesn't match my
company's word so I got a great question
a number of times the first time I came
up with in Malaysia when I was doing the
conference I believe that everybody has
one word that connects them that defines
them it's a one word biography when you
figure out what that word is it helps
make all decisions in your life a lot
easier helps make your market incisions
your helps make your partnership this is
easier every decision and your business
on your life becomes easier when you
know what you stand for so why does
believe and when I'm creating new
content for my web site for Twitter for
facebook when I'm making these videos it
has to be about believe because that's
who I am and it makes me happy and it
makes me excited and it drives me you
know I want to I want to see what I
creates am proud of that and not just be
creating it to try to get lots of view
that I actually like everything that I'm
making so I got a question at at in
Malaysia the conference somebody asks
you know what if you know I'm working on
that I work at a company and I'm working
on their social media campaigns but what
if you know my war doesn't match the
company's word what do i do and it's a
tough question you know i don't like
giving advice to employees because i
usually end up making them becoming
entrepreneurs but what I would advise
you to do when you're thinking about
working with other people you may not
always find that everybody has the exact
same board on your team and your circle
at the job your act so for example mine
is believe Jason who does a lot of work
with me his word is rise rich who does a
lot of work with me his word is inspire
and so these are not it's not exactly
believe but their sister words right
it's the reason why I can get along with
them because they have words that are
not exactly the same a very
complimentary and so if you're working
at a company and your word is very
complementary to what the company stands
for and it's going to be a good fit you
know you're going to be happy there
you're going to like the people there
you're going to be able to create
marketing campaigns that will mean
something then be important if you're
working on a company that doesn't stand
for anything or whose values are not
aligned with you or whose one word
doesn't match is that even close to what
yours is then
you're you know probably not gonna have
a good time working at that company and
you know no marketing plan is gonna save
you and you'd be better off finding a
different company that does match your
values or starting your own thing you
know my voice is jumping all over the
place I'm sick as a dog and running a
fever anyway this was important I wanted
to get it out so that's my advice if
your word does not match your company's
worth believe those you watching like
the video thumbs up below let me know
what you think leave a comment
underneath you can wish me to feel
better if you want you have a question
put it there i'll respond and now you
can click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much and I'll see
you see